[Music]
it's on the odd number year so 2019 it
comes up and then we'll hear it in 2021.
well i can tell you coach payne you win
a super bowl here in new orleans uh
jerry jones be willing to give you 20
million a year and all of a sudden you
get
man no no i'm being totally objective i
know but i'd like to keep them here but
i know that it's clearly the plan and
it's clearly the plan takes the
borderline tattoos that can't be erased
that was sean payton last week on wwl
radio look he's the saints head coach
he's on a new orleans station when they
ask him about possibly coaching the
dallas cowboys the last thing he's going
to say is yeah i can't wait to quit as
coach in the saints and go coach the
cowboys he it's a situation where you
must take the position that you're all
in with the saints but sharing you cover
the cowboys you've heard the rumors for
years
they're never going to go away until
sean payton retires from football
completely and entirely that link is
there that connection is there
and i re all due respect i mean like i
said he can't say what's really going on
and i think what's really going on is
he's keenly aware that no coach has won
a super bowl with two different
franchises he'd like to be the first and
there may be an opportunity to pursue a
championship with the dallas cowboys
coming up as soon as 2020.
yeah and i think we've always thought
that those two guys sean payton and drew
brees were kind of tied together and we
know drew brees his age and we know he's
at the end of his career now maybe teddy
bridgewater changes that view for sean
payton but all you have to do is connect
the dots i mean he was in dallas he
turned down oakland to stay in dallas as
an assistant coach he still has a house
here in dallas his kids grew up here
went to high school here all those
things still has a house here spends off
season here so all those things factor
in he and jerry are still tight maybe if
the cowboys had signed jason garrett
took contract extension that would have
kind of ended the talk but they didn't
the fact is jason garrett's going into
the season as a lame duck so those are
going to remain out there all season
long and until and if the cowboys signed
jason garrett to an extension
and the other factor that hovers over
the possibility and i'm just going to
say possibility i'm not saying it's
going to happen but the rumors do not go
away
sean payton to the cowboys you've got
dak prescott is the quarterback i'd love
to know what sean payton thinks of dak
prescott is that the guy that peyton
would want to carry into his tenure or
would peyton have ideas on someone else
that he thinks would be an upgrade i
mean it's clear the cowboys are all in
with prescott they're trying to sign
into a long-term deal but i feel like
that factor can't be ignored either and
maybe that's the thing that would keep
peyton from taking the job maybe he
doesn't believe that prescott would be
the best option to win uh the way that
peyton would want to
win yeah i completely agree with you
because once the cowboys do sign dak
prescott to a long-term deal they're
obviously committed to him for a long
time and they've said all the right
things about that but what if you do
what if you don't sign him this year you
get sean payton in here as your coach
will he want dak prescott as his
quarterback all those things factor into
it so if they do sign him maybe that
does keep sean payton away maybe he says
hey i'm better off with teddy
bridgewater in new orleans i like what
this kid can do i've seen him in my
offense uh in practice and i'd rather
teddy bridgewater than dak prescott
maybe that is the thing that keeps him
in new orleans is he believes in in
teddy bridgewater or a quarterback that
he can get in there if it's not teddy
bridgewater rather than dak prescott but
i do think there is something to the
rumors i do think that sean payton would
love to coach in dallas it's america's
team and to go win another super bowl
with another team it would put him in an
elite company as you said and if we
accept the premise that every coach that
has won a super bowl with one team is
keenly aware that no one has ever pulled
it off with a second team
it's not just the cowboys that i would
be looking at i i
when when you look at drew brees and
what what he built with brees over the
course of a decade plus i look at
cleveland and look freddie kitchens may
end up being the next vince lombardi i
was surprised that they hired freddie
kitchens although i think in their mind
hey it worked with him as the offensive
coordinator let's not throw this
possibility of kitchens being a great
head coach out the window and hire
someone else but there's going to be so
much pressure on kitchens whether it's
one two three years from now
if i'm sean payton i'm very intrigued by
coaching baker mayfield extremely
intrigued by that possibility as well
and and if and if the whole idea is go
to a place where you think you can win
another super bowl it doesn't matter
whether it's dallas or somewhere else
you're going to find the spot where you
think you're most most likely to push
that team to the top of the mountain
wherever that team may be located
yeah no question about it i just think
his relationship with jerry is special
and he knows jerry's gonna spend the
money and do the things that he wants to
do and i think he thinks he could be
like bill parcells of course he was here
with bill parcells but be like bill
parcells and the relationship that bill
had with jerry when bill was head coach
he thinks that's the sort of
relationship that jerry and sean can
have i'm sure i don't know that for a
fact but i'm just guessing
so i think his number one choice would
be dallas but absolutely if the goal is
to win another super bowl with another
team it may be better to go somewhere
else like a cleveland where you have a
quarterback that you really think can
can win
and you mention that relationship
between sean payton and jerry jones and
obviously that's going to be a critical
relationship if it would ever get to
that point but stephen jones has had
more and more involvement he's about the
same age as sean payton what do we know
about their relationship because that's
going to be the one if peyton would ever
end up in dallas that would endure well
into the future
yeah i think his relationship with jerry
is better but i do think he gets along
with stephen and you're right we know
just like we were talking about
quarterbacks at the end of the rank you
know jerry talks frequently about his
age and how he doesn't have a lot of
time left
to win which could prompt him to go out
and get a big name coach who's done it
and won a super bowl just like he did
with parcells but stephen and and sean
do have a good relationship i just think
his relationship with jerry shawn's
relationship with jerry is more special
i i also feel like jerry and this is
that roller coaster that he's been on
for the last 20 years where or longer
where you know jimmy johnson is the guy
that helps you win a couple of super
bowls and then you run him off and it
goes the other way as you try to figure
it out and then you bring in bill
parcells and it goes well again then you
run him off and i feel like they're just
getting to the point where
jerry and stephen are creating and
sustaining and getting the team toward
relevance and if you bring in to sean
payton and you basically give them the
keys to the car that kind of goes
against what jerry and steven have been
trying to do
well yeah they want to win however that
is and i think a coach might be able to
put them over the top they've always
obviously drafted very well over the
last few years they feel like they have
the people in place to get it done
all right well now that we've ended that
reckless speculation we're going to move
on to other things but it's important
because folks no matter what people say
that rumor is not going away
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports